Commonly reported symptoms of clinical
depression is a warped sense.
Everything can feel like it's moving in
super slow motion.
In fact,
depression warps everything around it
like a star warped spacetime that only
your sense of duration,
but also your sense of yourself and
others.
Your mental life is thrown out of all
proportion.
In his film,
Melancholia,
Lars von Trier uses skewed proportions
to communicate a feeling that he's
intimately familiar with.
You know,
when I ride,
I can only write about myself and this
is more or less a description of my,
my own depression.
The very first scene after the slow
motion montage that speaking of warp
time shows both the end of the film and
the end of world is the newly married
Justine and Michael trying to get from
the ceremony to the reception in a
stretch limo that is almost comically
too large for the country road that
they're driving.
Eventually they have to abandon the car
and walk,
and by the time they get to the castle
where the reception is,
half of the night has already been
wasted.
What's interesting is that the viewer
doesn't really feel that lightness.
We're only at the beginning of the film
and this I think gives us a hint of the
weird,
almost dreamlike temporal quality of the
wedding reception to come.
One thing that keeps getting stranger
and stranger to me as I rewatched the
film is the relationship between Justine
and Michael.
I mean at times it almost seems as if
they don't even know each other.
Michael seems to be completely unaware
of the severity of Justine's depression
and there are a few shots where Michael
just stares off blankly like a kind of
dead puppet.
Here.
Again,
things are skewed.
Volunteer doesn't give us a sense of the
couple's past,
but I'm getting ahead of myself.
The first half of the film is made up of
the wedding reception,
alternating between the party and
justine's various exits as she falls
deeper and deeper into an oncoming bout
of depression inventory or uses the
reception itself to set up an
expectation of continuous time,
but Justin's exits make this
problematic.
The two parts of the sequence don't seem
to fit together.
Justine rides off in a golf cart all the
way across the ground.
She languishes in a bath,
but the party is always there,
always still happening when she returns
to it in moods that are increasingly
detached,
even within the party time jumps forward
at the whim of volunteers,
disorienting editing,
the film critic Marta grow.
It's drew my attention to the fact that,
for example,
the newlyweds first dance is actually a
montage of justine dancing with a number
of people while the song underneath it,
La Bomba plays continuously.
What all of this adds up to is an
unsettling feeling of subjectivity,
of feeling that you're in the head of
justine and by extension,
volunteer who's attempts to get a handle
on things to lock everything in place
are upset,
and then finally dashed.
No one in the film seems capable of
measuring things correctly,
whether it's the number of beans in a
jar,
2,000,006
piece,
or the correct trajectory of a rope
planet.
Everything that's handled,
Burns,
creases or shatters,
and we ought to mention the several
artistic references volunteer makes in
the film,
many of which are in the very first
sequence.
The most obvious is this shot,
which sites John Everett Malays Painting
Ofelia after the character in
Shakespeare's hamlet,
who is perhaps the most famous
depressive in all of literature.
Then we have an actual shot of Roy
goals,
hunters in the snow,
a painting of hunters coming back to
their village empty handed,
which calls to mine another science
fiction film concerned with the depths
of the soul.
Andre Tarkovsky is Solaris.
The volunteer is a massive fan of
Tarkovsky and there are other
similarities here to sell.
Ours,
for example,
makes great use of box coral prelude in
f minor,
repeating it throughout the film and as
he's written,
Tarkovsky likes to use music as a
reframe.
The refrain brings us back to our first
experience of entering the poetic world,
making it immediate,
and at the same time renewing it
voluntary or uses the same technique in
Melancholia with wagner is a prelude to
Tristan and his old,
a romantic song that speaks to how the
filmmaker mixes his meditation on
depression with beauty,
like a glowing blue planet and desire.
And there are plenty of other references
to like those to elaine.
Rene's last year at Mary and bought
another film with a dream like narrative
structure,
and of course these early shots jump
forward to reference,
but not exactly replicate later moments
in the film.
Melancholia is no doubt a polarizing
film.
It's beauty is undeniable,
but I'm sure many will argue that it
lacks coherence or focus and need.
I have my own problems with the second
part of the film,
but this is one of the most striking
portrayals to me of a disease that
affects so many,
but which is still so little understood
in my view.
Depression is what happens when your
identity,
that sense of the relationship you have
with the world around you becomes
untethered and focused.
In this process,
everything starts to skew.
Time slows to a standstill.
Your body wants so easy to move.
It feels like it weighs a ton for a
person.
Memories start to become disorganized.
The memories of a film,
on the other hand are all those works of
art that informed and proceeded.
Perhaps this is why Vaughan tree or
surrounds his characters with so many.
By the time we get to the second half of
the film,
extraordinary situation,
the approach of the rogue planet,
Melancholia,
warps,
even the characters dispositions,
justine emerging slowly from the depths
of her illness reacts to the existential
situation with calm.
Claire on the other hand,
hurt seeing other half begins to panic.
The film in the end takes on the disease
of its main character.
I,
for one,
am happy to see a film.
So Ernest,
about sadness as it stands,
science and medicine have come up short
in their apprehension of mental illness.
So maybe we ought to look to art for
insights and solidarity about what it's
like living a life out of proportion.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Sorry,
this video is a little bit late.
I had a horrible stomach flu yesterday
that was just destroying me.
Um,
but I feel much better now and I love
this film.
You know,
I have certain problems with it,
but I think there's so much of value
here.
And I love the opportunity to talk about
depression and mental illness through
the lens of a film like this.
Um,
so I hope you guys liked it.
if you want to play through this
channel,
you can go right here and pledge a
dollar or $3 per video on Patrion page.
Everything helps.
You guys have been amazing.
Thank you for watching my q and a last
week.
That was a lot of final.
Definitely do more and I will see you
guys next Wednesday.